[Music]
on this monday night russia's ruthless
relentless attacks
homes hit civilians targeted as ukraine
keeps fighting back
plus the alberta man helping hospitals
the exhausting escape for ukrainians as
essentials run out and pressure mounts
on canada to do more we hear from
canada's defense minister there
certainly is
a need to move as quickly as possible
and influencing the public perception of
war
the young woman using tick-tock to
document life on the ground in ukraine
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
on this 12th day of russia's war on
ukraine people are on the run taking
only what they can carry
the city is almost ruined in the
district where i'm living it's
like no houses which were not bombed
yesterday there was
the
the hottest woman
she and her children are fleeing urpin
half an hour from keeve people inching
their way across the river ukraine blew
up the bridge here to slow the russian
advance but that has not stopped the
bombardment by artillery and missiles
other cities in the south east and north
are under siege too hundreds of
thousands in mariopol trapped without
running water power and sanitation and
with dwindling food
good evening and thanks for joining us
russia promised another humanitarian
corridor but all routes led to russia or
its ally belarus and ukraine's president
condemned it as an immoral stunt
which
and tonight he posted another video
pointing his phone out the window to
prove he is still in his office in kiev
another round of peace talks today ended
with no hope the pentagon says that
russian that russian military convoy on
a highway near kiev is still stalled and
that russia has now turned to syria to
try to recruit more soldiers
we have complete coverage tonight
abigail beeman is traveling with prime
minister justin trudeau mercedes
stevenson is in latvia jackson proskow
is in washington and mike armstrong is
in la vie ukraine that's where our
coverage begins tonight
russian shelling is leaving death
destruction and disbelief
this is a village about 20 kilometers
north of keefe the fighting is outside
the village but local residents say
russian missiles have hit homes
repeatedly
what are they doing this man asks a
family with two young children and two
grandparents lived here
there was less shelling on this day but
it was happening despite talks between
the two sides ukraine's second biggest
city was hit with heavy shelling in the
early hours this family was in the
hallway on the fifth floor of their
apartment building
say a rocket hit somewhere below them
the floor collapsed under their feet and
neighbors on floors underneath were
killed
even in hospitals there's fear
explosions are heard by patients on
stretchers medics and doctors simply
keep going i see bubba make sure
thank you so much for saving us she says
what would we do without you
there was hope humanitarian corridors
might move people to safety they didn't
work the russian military opened some
but most led to russia and belarus for
most ukrainians fleeing to the country
that's invading theirs wasn't an option
the russian military admits no one used
the humanitarian corridors but accuses
the ukrainian side of not releasing
civilians and threatening them with
violence
the ukrainian side meantime calls the
idea of asking refugees to go to russia
or belarus quote completely immoral and
says vladimir putin surrounded by yes
man what needs to be done is for
president putin to start talking start
the dialogue instead of living in the
informational bubble without oxygen i
think that's where he is
in the west no fighting but fatigue the
battles are an hour away but not far
enough people in la viv are preparing
fortifying some buildings this lineup
was for civilians to register to be
given weapons
and they've stockpiled molotov cocktails
to the point they've stopped production
they are also worrying about the
conflict zones this calgary man spent
his day running from pharmacy to
pharmacy he was born in ukraine and came
back to help collecting medical supplies
to ship east got a list yesterday
and it's going to be in the hospital
tomorrow
now the supplies are things like
medications gloves and bandages they
usually send them by train one of the
hard parts about doing that he says is
going to the train station and seeing
the sad faces of the people getting off
who've just escaped the fighting
and left everything behind
i spoke to mike armstrong in la viv
before the night time curfew was in
place
mike i saw a picture you tweeted of
levin darkness the lights out it's
silent it must feel like a city that's
just
waiting that's a great way to put it
actually donna there hasn't been any
bombing in this region of western
ukraine but no one thinks it can't
happen here also there are rumors out
there stories about possibly saboteurs
or spies who are in town working for the
other side possibly even marking targets
so this is very much a city on edge and
you mentioned that curfew it's in place
from
10 pm to 6 a.m you're not supposed to go
outside you're not supposed to have
lights on
it is surreal when you look out from our
hotel at night it is so quiet and it's
strange because this is very much a
country that is right now at war and
mike there are two different narratives
about that war the one the russian
people are being told through
state-controlled media in that country
and what the rest of the world is
hearing when it comes to civilian
casualties
what's the reality
yeah we do have some numbers from the
united nations today since february 24th
so in 12 days they're saying 406 people
have been killed 801 injured but those
are very much just confirmed documented
cases and they say the number is
actually very likely much higher they're
also saying that most of the deaths and
injuries have been caused by shelling
rockets and missile attacks and quickly
mike i know russian forces have made
advances in the south and the east it's
best that you can tell
what's the situation like for people
under russian
control not good uh the ukrainian
government says uh russian troops are
not allowing aid to get in there are
stories about private citizens who are
trying to move aid in and they're being
turned around by russian troops uh even
shot at and threatened there are also
stories out there right now about those
protests that we're seeing on social
media people who are going into town
squares with ukrainian flags singing the
ukrainian national anthem things like
that in front of russian troops there
was a case yesterday on sunday
in a city just north of crimea actually
where russian troops would have opened
fire on a crowd one person was killed
seven people were injured it really is
important to remember the danger those
people are putting themselves in
to make the point they want to make
mike armstrong in la vie ukraine thanks
thank you
the exodus of people from ukraine is
growing more than 1.7 million people
have now fled ukraine the canadian
government is allowing ukrainians who
have fled russian aggression to come to
canada for up to two years but those who
were not ukrainian citizens are not
eligible the immigration minister says
they will be given priority when they
apply through the usual immigration
channels
prime minister justin trudeau is in the
region he stopped in london on route to
latvia he met the prime ministers of
britain and the netherlands discussing
what more can be done to support ukraine
and wean europe off russian oil abigail
beeman is traveling with the prime
minister
clive martinez has lived in london all
his life but this is his first visit to
the russian embassy his heart he says is
with people suffering and he accepts
that standing up to russia will have
ripple effects in his life and on his
wallet i think we should be as tough as
possible to get this stopped russian gas
russian oil all of that yes i think you
know it's it's going to be painful for
us
to to do without some of that we should
we should take some of that pain the
painful reality is that we are still
very much dependent on russian gas and
russian oil russian oil and gas top of
mind in europe as leaders figure out
whether it's possible to turn off the
taps canada promised a ban but has only
imported negligible amounts of crude
from russia in recent years we're gonna
have to look for supply we're gonna have
to look for substitute supplies uh from
elsewhere asked whether canada will send
oil europe's way justin trudeau was
vague we will be there to support as the
world moves beyond russian oil and
indeed beyond fossil fuels
details vague too about the
international support group the british
prime minister announced the uk
netherlands and canada are starting
together
separately boris johnson pledged 175
million pounds almost 300 million
dollars canadian to support ukraine
while trudeau announced canada is
sanctioning another 10 russians
the british prime minister
is showing real leadership with a real
plan
and he's now trying to socialize that
plan and trying to get input into that
plan
there has been no strategy by canada
when it comes to a plan in terms of
ukraine trudeau repeated there is more
to do to help ukraine citing nearly a
billion dollars worth of financial
assistance and humanitarian aid already
pledged but exactly how far canada is
willing to go is not clear certainly the
subject of conversations with more
european leaders in the coming days
abigail beeman global news london
the ukrainian president will address the
uk parliament by a video link tomorrow
vladimir zelinski is in constant contact
with western leaders the new york times
reports the u.s provided him with
encrypted communications equipment he
has made it clear from the start of the
war he needs more than russian sanctions
and weapons he wants planes and a no-fly
zone our mercedes stevenson is in latvia
and spoke with canada's defense minister
and she wants to help the helplessness
is agonizing for lisa binhayatska a
ukrainian surgical nurse now a refugee
she fled kiev when the fighting started
reuniting in latvia with her childhood
best friend olga lefkowska
she's been welcomed but lisa wants
nothing more than to go back and help
are you afraid to go back
no she or she wants to call right now
i'm stopping her because i don't think
that's safe and she's definitely not
going to help anyone when she's dead
these women don't know if or when they
can go home but they have one plea for
western governments in nato create a
no-fly zone over ukraine we understand
why why nato doesn't want to do that but
this is
this is very important for us and this
is urgent we put that plea to the
defense minister here in riga i feel
extremely empathetic to that sentiment
but anita anand says the risk of war
between the u.s and russia to rival
nuclear powers is too great enforcing a
no-fly zone
would
lead to a severe
and certain escalation
of hostilities but there might be
another way canada can help ukraine with
aerial support
this is the bhairaktar combat drone it's
been used with devastating effectiveness
by the ukrainian military
images of its strikes can be found
online and over social media its
precision camera is canadian made anan
says the government is looking at
supplying more of that technology to
ukraine we are
actively examining ways in which we
could assist the ukrainian army with
that equipment canada has promised
anti-tank weapons as well to support
ukrainian forces but military sources
tell global news there are major
challenges in delivering them the
minister would not confirm or deny that
but insisted the weapons will make it to
people in ukraine i have been assured
through our sources that our aid will be
able to flow and at this point that's
all i can say until it is successfully
and safely delivered for now ukrainians
are desperate for any help they hope is
coming soon
as for canada's capabilities the defense
minister hinted at increased defense
spending and possibly accelerated
procurements on things like new fighter
jets in the near future
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
riga latvia tonight thanks russians
against the war are being rounded up on
the streets
there were multiple protests in russia
yesterday human rights groups say more
than 4 500 anti-war protesters were
arrested in more than 50 russian cities
and that more than 13 000 have been
detained since russia began this war
ukraine's president says russia is
preparing to bomb odessa a strategically
important city on ukraine's black sea
coast odessa is preparing this photo of
a road sign was taken by sean walker for
the guardian newspaper it says straight
ahead f off left f off again right
f off to russia
the weapons on the way to ukraine coming
up who is sending what and what are they
capable of
[Music]
nato has said repeatedly it does not
want to risk triggering a wider war with
russia by getting directly involved in
the conflict many member countries are
sending weapons though here's part of
what's arrived in the last week the u.s
and nato have sent more than 17 000
anti-tank weapons including javelin
missiles canada is committing to sending
25 million dollars worth of equipment
including night vision gear and at least
100 carl gustaf anti-tank weapon systems
plus 2 000 rounds of ammunition
jackson proskow reports on what those
weapons are capable of
the allied airlift has unfolded with
remarkable speed western weapons are
offloaded at airfields in poland and
romania driven across the border
and delivered into the hands of the
ukrainian army and its newest fighters
russia has come into my home says this
teacher turned soldier i cannot stay at
home when our country is in danger
there's extreme urgency to the mission
as russian forces continue their advance
there's concern they could choke off the
supply of military support
in the hands of the ukrainian army
american anti-tank missiles have proven
devastatingly effective allegedly
destroying hundreds of russian tanks
western anti-aircraft missiles could be
used to down russian aircraft
body armor helmets and rifles are
arriving too all courtesy of nato allies
this is going to be a long game
for the western unity and that
must must
stay
in place as russia gains more ground
nato members have only increased the
frantic pace of shipments even working
on a deal to supply polish fighter jets
to the ukrainian air force there are a
number of challenging practical
questions including how the planes would
actually be transferred from poland to
ukraine and as the weapons move in
they're joined by a growing number of
volunteer fighters from around the world
basically we're here because of the war
crimes that are being committed
ukrainian officials claim 20 000
volunteers from 52 nations have now
signed up to repel the russians but
external support is not limited to
ukraine and its allies the pentagon
believes russia is now trying to recruit
foreign fighters from syria men who are
experienced in the type of devastating
urban combat that russia is now
inflicting on ukraine jackson prosko
global news washington
this conflict is fueling a surge in the
price of oil crude oil soared to a near
14-year high today almost 140 u.s a
barrel canadians are feeling the pinch
at the pumps with record high gas prices
today alberta's premier jason kenney
announced his province will stop
collecting a fuel tax he says the price
at the pump will drop by 13 cents a
liter the alberta government will also
deliver a 150 rebate on electricity
bills starting april first one of the
leading organizers of the so-called
freedom convoy that occupied ottawa's
downtown core for three weeks has been
granted bail tamara leech is from
alberta was released on strict bail
conditions and 25 000 in bonds she must
leave ottawa within 24 hours stay off
social media and not allow anyone to
post messages on her behalf and she
cannot communicate with other protest
organizers facing charges
love and war ahead a ukrainian couple
gets their special day in the face of
crisis
elizabeth met with prime minister justin
trudeau at windsor castle today the 95
year old's first in-person engagement
since she was diagnosed with covet-19.
queen elizabeth met canada's prime
minister for 45 minutes he was in london
for talks on the war in ukraine there
was a vase of blue and yellow flowers
and the queen wore a delicate yellow and
blue print seen as a subtle message of
support for ukraine
at the end of this week the pandemic
will enter its third year today in a
sign things are far from over the global
death toll from covid19 surpassed 6
million
poor record-keeping testing and
under-reporting of covid19 deaths
especially in countries like mexico
india and africa means the real death
toll is likely much higher
there was some good news announced by
moderna today to help slow transmission
rates in east africa the company reached
a memorandum of understanding to build a
covet 19 manufacturing facility in kenya
the company's first in africa moderna
plans to invest 500 million dollars to
produce mrna vaccines with a goal of
manufacturing 500 million doses each
year
next revealing the reality of war
through a popular social media site
[Music]
technology has changed how wars are
fought and how the public sees them
without cameras on every phone the world
would be blind to much of what's going
on in ukraine now platforms like tick
tock allow information to spread
worldwide in seconds heather urex west
has the story of one young woman whose
stories of life in war are captivating
millions
75 years ago a teenager's diary became
one of the most powerful accounts to
emerge from the second world war
of course the world would only learn
about anne frank's diary and daily life
under nazi occupation after her death
but what if she and others like her
could have shared their stories sooner
does that mean we would have a different
understanding of the war while it is
proceeding rather than afterwards
from her home in ukraine valeria
shashanok isn't keeping a traditional
diary
instead like many people her age she has
a tick-tock account and her videos have
gone viral
when you you follow somebody on tick
tock who's just a regular person like
anybody else is a regular person and
then the next day
their country has been invaded right and
their their daily life now is uh look at
me in this underground bunker uh look at
me in this empty grocery store it makes
the war
shashanok's videos are both shocking and
familiar
a young life so entirely relatable here
in canada suddenly upended by war
her tick tock's now earning millions of
views around the world it's a remarkably
powerful set of testimonies that
everyday people are sharing i think it's
really important that these materials
are being published and consumed in the
middle of the conflict and not just
after it's all gone
a documentation via viral dance app it's
now an accounting of history being
broadcast in real time a young woman's
real life
playing out amid so much uncertainty
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with a sign that life and love
go on even in war
[Music]
this couple both members of ukraine's
volunteer forces married on the
outskirts of kiev on sunday they've been
together 22 years and decided to marry
now because they fear they could die at
any moment
they say they planned a quiet ceremony
but their friends surprised them with
something a little grander
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]